pour le bloc québécois on peut compter
mais denis trudel est le candidat du
bloc québécois dans longueuil
saint-hubert comté où il a fini 3e 2015
derrière le npd et les libéraux
à une semaine du vote il n'a jamais été
aussi optimiste l'ambiance était très
bonne les excellentes très bon film
l'argent qui rentre dans les cordes du
parti énormément de gens que je ne
connais même pas même optimisme dans la
circonscription voisine de longueuil
charles lemoyne ou la candidate
bloquiste 4,6 lepage fait pourtant face
à la députée libérale sortante chéri
romanado on a plein de gens qui nous
soit par courriel soit qu'ils nous
appellent ou par messenger qui nous
disent on a du temps on peut vous donner
un peu de temps à la dernière campagne
on offrait un autre des clients les gens
parfois même nous l'a refusé
alors que l'acea oui le bloc où le bloc
oui non c'est très très lors de notre
visite au local de denis trudel se
citoyens indécis en début de campagne
est d'ailleurs venu proposer son aide ou
bloc québécois on regarde les choix ça
et pour longueuil c'est vraiment le bloc
mais dans les deux comtés longueuillois
l'adversaire libéral s'appuie sur une
grosse machine électorale lundi matin au
local du candidat vedette réjean hébert
un ancien ministre péquiste
ils étaient une vingtaine de bénévoles a
préparé le dernier blitz de séduction
parce que la montée du blog vous fait
pas non c'est normal dans les campagnes
et des hauts et des bas comme aux
attentes au moment donné des réactions
une autre situation mais on est sur le
terrain sans peau là depuis le début
le bloc est l'adversaire principal de ce
conte ici donc la lutte est chaude je
suis habitué à être dans des comtés où
la lutte est chaude donc je sais
l'importance du port tapas suis le
candidat du parti libéral aux prochaines
élections région et d'air qui dit avoir
cogné à 3000 porte depuis le début de la
campagne avait gagné son élection par 65
voix seulement en 2012 pour le parti
québécois se compter de ce lundi 5 ans
qu'il est dans l'opposition alors je
pense que ce soit c'est quelque chose
qui résonne chez les citoyens
notre travail cette semaine ça va de
contacter les citoyens de les pointer et
jour du vote de faire sortir ce vote là
le bloc québécois connaîtra-t-il ou non
une véritable renaissance longueuil
offrira une partie de la réponse lundi
prochain ici jean sébastien cloutier
radio-canada longueur